Now we showed how useful it is to have an API
for regular expressions that we can say
for example plus an option, alternative of literal A, literal B
and these function calls are convenient to manipulate
but that’s an awful lot to type,
especially when the string notation for
regular expressions is so much simpler,
we can represent this as this simple string,
and so what I want you to do in this homework
is to write a grammar and a parser that maps
from this string to this expression.
So you should first define regular expression grammar
using the tools that we’ve provided,
build the parser for that, that’s going to give you a tree,
so when we parse let’s say, RE is our main symbol,
then some text with this grammar
then that’s going to give you some sort of tree,
but it’s not quite this API form,
so then I want you to write another function to convert
from the tree to the API,
and so here’s what it looks like.
You are going to define your grammar,
RE is going to be the main left-hand side symbol
to parse the regular expression that’s given for you,
you parse it and convert it
and then you have to convert this
to make that cause into the API.